hello
hola buenos noches Bienvenidos welcome
in Viva podcast why is it so loud from
this mic oh yeah that does sound pretty
loud
wow you're allowed too hello hello hello
hello hola hello hello
hello hello
sir oh wait that went down too much hey
what what do you think about the economy
uh
uh man I wish uh people would be
focusing more on making craft
methamphetamines instead of craft beer I
think the economy can be better you
think that we should do more crazy drugs
uh maybe
we were a better country when we were
crystallizing Sudafed not turning banana
breads into ipas that's my opinion
since the IPA so you wish for the 90s to
come back late 90s early 2000s yeah man
that was a good time what do you like so
much about uh Aaron Carter
and
you killed me with XC dust what is that
called the sugar little pack pixie sugar
pixie stick yeah man that that was a
Gateway uh to drugs for me man I used to
pretend that that was a like Coke that I
was doing then like a few months later I
was actually doing coke
oh a few months so yeah like uh I think
I started uh that substance in like
eighth grade
pixie dust yeah pixie dust and then Coke
eighth grade that was a crazy eighth
grade you went from zero to a hundred no
uh not yet uh back then the coke was a
little uh was a little better than it is
now I feel like back then we had real
cocaine now it's like just like ketamine
nowadays it ain't the real ketamine dog
so you went from pixie dust to real
cocaine that's right I guess that's a
lot
what happened my life has been a lot
what happened
um summer school happened I think that's
when I did it
I got kicked out of summer school for
being high on mushrooms and laughing my
ass off me and my friend Kevin there was
a song like I started before summer
school if you're doing summer school and
doing mushrooms at summer school
I never did mushrooms or summer school
yeah I was I was [__] so I did
summer school
retardo
retardo like my people would say
I think that you should do whatever you
want to do thanks dog I feel that I
should too and I feel like you should do
the same thing too
are you are you deleting that or
something yeah
none of this is going out I think you're
having a private conversation yeah I
figured just kidding it's going out yo
so how do you feel about the oh
then n words no
the namibians nah
boobians Nubians nah Namibia the people
from Namibia Namibia they're namibians
right
have you ever had
nevermctomy nah do you get all your
namibians parts cut cut out that's what
they say if you're a namibian immigrant
and you're acting too white they're like
oh he had a
nibectomy get that [__] out number back
to me
back to me that's what they have in
Korea it's called the Korean ectomy
what do they call it for Native
Americans
they say you're not real you're probably
just Mexican
back to the reservation they say you
don't exist anymore as a people that's
right we exterminated you quite
ruthlessly
straight up it's like oh yeah they wrote
like Native Americans are scum and we
should exterminate them but it's like to
actually have your president say that is
like a whole nother level yeah it's uh
you know there's only two countries in
the history of the of the world that
have required citizens to measure their
blood Quantum and that was Nazi Germany
and second was the United States with
Native Americans
well Hitler got a lot of his ideas from
uh extermination
that's a fact sir and British
concentration camps they're the first to
have concentration camps of British and
Africa somewhere oh Germany was sort of
late to the imperialism game the guess
it was like the Dutch but I think I I
think I think that because I just think
of like King Leopold and how horrible he
was but I'm sure he wasn't the first one
I'm sure that he wasn't he was just
doing what everyone then back then was
doing
it was like Hey if I don't cut off these
people's hands somebody else will yeah
and they won't get the rubber yeah you
know who got uh most of the benefits
from that as his mistress yeah also
milking him she was just [__] him and
taking all his money so all these poor
[__] Congolese were working for the
queen for this [__]
a mistress dog the [__] that would
never be queen
look but the thing is like back then
they didn't have good [__] they didn't
have like doordash so she was spending
money on like Silk Cuts yeah like in
China and [__] yeah and silk from Turkey
who needs that like yeah like
blades from Syria
I don't think she was into that
you never know um so how was your night
comedy probably wise it was uh it was
all right man uh I quit at the end so
I'm not happy about it I'm not happy
about that I went to challenge well that
was a good time to quit is that the end
yeah I'm glad you didn't quit at the
middle true but every end could have
been a middle if you didn't quit it was
fun though man I wouldn't challenge Mike
and then I did uh I went over to
Anderson Mill
nice yeah man back to my roots Anderson
Mill yeah you gotta go see my cool deck
every now somewhere the guy went in with
a gun and shot three bullets he missed
every single one I don't think the gun
went off I think I think it did okay
either way yes that is where the guy
went and didn't kill nobody and then
left there's such beta energy no he got
tackled he got arrested yeah man I don't
know okay maybe it was a video it may be
multiple times at this place
it has that energy and it's a little Pub
yeah it's like people that's where
people are it's like a pub for people
it's in a strip mall bro there's no
public Brands up there you are that is
you're not lying like that that's how
yeah that's a thermometer yeah it's like
a core sample just oh look this is the
people of America's people yeah that's
that's who that they're not faking
anything they're there because that's
why I like that room that's the best
place for them to be at that point but I
couldn't stay there till one o'clock in
the morning to do uh
uh audience
same as always the same five regulars
and then the same 30 Comics who are the
regulars that go to this Open Mic don't
do comedy and have very sad lives in the
middle of I have no idea I hope they
near live near that Pub I hope they're
not commuting I'm pretty sure they
should be near that point I appreciate
that for being there but I have no idea
what they do I feel you're not curious
you didn't ever think about doing crowd
work
not at that place I don't think they're
with it they're turned around the room
yeah that's a good that's a good crowd
at Anderson Mill if it's bad then hey I
don't even care what you [__]
thinking about we're painful [__] oh
yeah it wasn't yeah
Anderson Mill there's always an Anderson
Mill in every city San Antonio it's
called The Elbow Room
in Seattle it's called the Space Needle
what if that's what if we use the space
needle for like a good public use like
you could just go to the Space Needle
and just you know do things that actual
humans do not just tourists like imagine
what imagine if there was an Anderson
Mill pub at the top of the Space Needle
okay
why not you don't want to be around
dangerous people with one Escape path no
yeah
uh-oh doorbell yeah you want to do a
solo I sure are we are you open the eyes
are you live are there people on yes
there's people watching oh yeah dude
y'all want to see me rolling this is
really live right now all right go get
the door I might roll a blunt nah man go
down I'm gonna say some [__] man I gotta
open it from here
I'm gonna hijack the podcast say about
that you can't
You Wanna Smoke sure
I gotta roll it
hey
yes
go come up the stairs don't be weird
yeah you [__] Norwegian
more like horror region oh [__] we got
one of those huh
yeah
this is uh Andreas
be careful damn dog this is kind of like
a janky setup
oh no
cool earrings
got a bigger table
nah why would we
no it's perfect it's good enough dog
this is good enough for King Arthur
Stanford yeah manly and masculine
this is sort of like a redneck that
lives in Norway yeah oh that's what's up
where is Norway on the map
that's a really American of you to say
no
that's what I was going to ask and as
far as like the because there's two
dicks up north hanging down because
that's where your country is right it
looks like a [__] just like a flaccid
penis so which one is it is it the one
like he answered it main dig I don't
know the main softy cool
cool how do you feel about America is
the one that everyone thinks sounds
funny right
what Danish Denmark people
it's not completely even
say the thing no I think so just relax
just say anything you want right now how
do you feel about the juice
he's [__] traffic
this is not the guy I want to do a
podcast what's your name Hank
you smell like a Norwegian truck stop
am I getting jobs
it's drink a lot it's a drinker I think
oh you do you do a lot of drinks should
I go get drinks uh yeah I can get him
and drink yeah out in Norway which is
we're like Irish of the north oh okay
that that yeah that that puts it into
perspective for me now
in Norway
so what do you think about the north men
have you seen it uh yeah that's the TV
TV show the movie
there's a North man I thought it was
Norseman Norseman is Norseman something
else there must be a TV show that's what
I thought
this one with Alexander skarskagard
Skarsgard
what are the mexic who are the Mexicans
in Norway
Muslims but they got to have a country
how did they get there
are they Moroccans
many many yeah we're about to get a lot
more ever since that damn earthquake
just versus shook them up hey get out of
there hey so
what about like from you look like the
New York yeah
you went to Morocco look at him you
would hate the Moroccans
I booked the trip when I was drunk is
that better yeah this sounds better yeah
you booked a trip when you were drunk
yeah and I woke up and like oh [__] I'm
going to Morocco tomorrow now it's like
four days damn yeah
but I went to serve serve to Surf yeah
cool I didn't know they had beaches like
surfing beaches I was pretty good surf
there I'm pretty famous for it I have
really good surf a lot of dick about
surfing so no that settles that the only
thing I know about surfing is rocket
power the cartoon
what's that surfing is all about using
the energy of the ocean
uh you know utilizing it efficiently
instead of bleeding it off to the sides
you gotta use it and then you can feel
the ocean moving underneath you it
doesn't kind of
[__] deep explanation when you said
that I just trying to lose my physics I
blacked out and I just heard it's an
Asian description Bruce Lee like Watson
like I want to be watching my friends
like a wave a way it becomes the teapot
you put water in it I like that one
yeah hell yeah yeah it makes me get up
in the morning
be like water yeah water on a bed it
becomes the best
yeah I used to be
people used to be what happened she
wasn't you moved up to poop don't be a
[__] yeah come on what is uh Norway
like with the Trans stuff are they more
advanced or less advanced than America
ah we have uh too few uh too few Trends
yeah it's like a small city right it's
like a family you rate your trans like
are they are they like eight sixes no
like uh you can use me translator
they're pretty hot they look like
[__] women but in Norway it's just
like a [__] guy with a bear just
making a state they don't have a good
culture they don't have a rich tapestry
of Trends to draw they're pretty liberal
like but we don't have like um black
people we don't have enough weirdos yeah
we have
black people but there's no Somalian oh
okay so they don't do gangster rap it
just steals yeah
they just try to steal your boat yeah
they just get angry at you for polluting
their natural waterways and then they
take it out by yeah I'm a sailor
actually so I was supposed to my dream
was to like sail through the canal and
shoot yeah
that's a cool dream man yeah
you definitely have the haircut for that
dream hell yeah dude how long have you
been doing comedy uh I think it's six uh
coming up on six years now why do I feel
like I just saw you recently uh she was
on kill tone he was on kill Tony it
hasn't come out yet though right no okay
that's why oh you were at the show yeah
you know is that the show he's always
watching I guess it's perfect he's the
guy in the shadow yeah okay yeah yeah
he's a big shout out
overcast yeah
yeah that's right the Sam talent's
shadow it's professionally disguised
what he's smaller than you no he's not
really exactly you guys are similar kind
of all right maybe he's like a waiter
you're taller than I'm a little taller
no I actually think he's taller okay
it's not a contest who knows it's not
that dude's hilarious though he killed
it tonight did he I wish I'm not even
gonna reveal any of his bits because
that would be my baby
you want to scoot over towards me a
little bit that one is a little drink
are you good now yeah okay you can shove
the some of those cards under there
figure
public education to figure it out I was
just school over there do you all play
games like smear the queer
smeared to queer do you have to explain
that one
it's like tag but involuntarily would
you just suck a guy off
smeared
smear the queer come all over your face
uh we do like tag but it's like tag
you're it and if you don't give it to
somebody in
um within 20 seconds you're gay and you
have to go home and you have to jerk off
to gay porn oh hell yeah yeah lights out
of country so we get in fights and [__]
oh y'all are Scrappy y'all fight yeah
yeah look at it not everyone in Norway
is a [__] you have one tattoo yeah
that's fine
well the thing about Norway is that
that's like in the Scandinavian area
there's a lot of Death Metal and like
heavy metal people to come because
they're so happy that they have to
produce sadness for no reason yeah but
then when they go off stage they go home
and they drink tea yeah
Healthcare is nice yeah they're not
hardcore oh we had that one guy who shot
himself yeah and he put it on an album
cover I was like yeah Norway go away no
let's go what's your claim to fame do
you guys have like a time of the year
where everyone's cheering for Norway
like you know Germany has the World Cup
we have Independence Day what is
independence we got independent from uh
from uh the union and like yeah we got
our own like law and [__] so like one
day a year 17th of May the whole is like
insane party time yeah it's like a whole
country and it's like that's beautiful
yeah 17th of May so it's like the Soviet
Union so 89.90 was when you get
independence you gotta ask some other
questions man you don't want to talk
about this uh no it's um and
um it's uh we don't want to know you
don't know and now he's he's a surprise
no but he doesn't want to have to start
here I don't know what's going on right
now I felt some big island
no he would never no I would never
don't make me look like a focus you just
look you don't look like
um you just look like something yeah but
if I have like if I have your hair I'll
be constantly doing this like you're a
nervous Nancy yeah it [__] me up yeah
because yeah yeah you're like I can't
deal with hair I gotta focus on that's
why we're my Manifesto take it out
so you don't want to talk about Norway
yeah I can talk about Norway like uh
what do you guys think about nor do you
think we ride on polar bears I wish that
we could adopt a lot of their policies
and the way they look at life because
they're actually trying to make a
country that they can live in
yeah but we also have a lot of money so
it's pretty easy to where'd that money
come from oil
well America we have quite a bit of
money as well yeah a lot of people or
capita I don't know let's let's measure
like one American city and we have also
y'all don't have stars and stripes how
many countries need to have a flag with
a cross on it
yeah all the Christians one should yeah
no it's terrible I mean don't talk bad
about the cross it's my flag man
Stars and Stripes but this is the Lone
Star State so one star
one star you don't call it Lone Star
Lone Star reviews
star reviews
you know where the the Lone Star came
from yeah Jose Antonio Garza
um
a relative of Hank Garza a descendant uh
from yeah
you mean your ancestors your ancestry I
[__] that one up yeah sorry about that
um Jose Antonio Garcia came up with he
uh printed
uh he made coins for the Republic of
Texas actually I think this was before
we were even no this is before the
Republic of Texas this was like in 1813
18 yeah 1813. he put a uh one star on a
uh on a coin and that was the like our
our ma like our money and that's where
it came from okay so they yeah they
tried to whitewash uh see a lot of
things that happens with Texas history
people think that Texas didn't exist
before the white man came here like oh
yeah a white man came here and then
everything else came but it wasn't cool
though yeah what was it before the
whites
uh it was part of New Spain it was
always called Texas even in New Spain it
was it was a province of New Spain
called uh it was called the Tejas Texas
yeah I'm glad they changed it
yeah man I mean Spanish people they just
came here they just owned everything
they made everyone speak their language
they killed babies they raped everybody
they made that's not really Colombian
sexy
well
yeah but kind of but not in Texas but I
was talking about like South America
true true very true I [__] up South
America for that silver yeah but it's
kind of crazy how everyone speaks
Spanish now you're very successful here
in Texas uh what they got freedom in
Texas and the reason why I say they got
freedom was um there was no cattle
business in the world
prior to like for the spaniers prior to
them coming here and then instead of
them like well there's a new Avenue it's
like well [__] cattle and horses were
just were worth so much money back in
the day I mean still now but yeah yeah
back then yeah but I actually thought
like uh this is what I actually thought
it was called The Lone Star Little Star
State yeah but it was because like you
had this deal that you can break out of
that's a myth
that we can succeed whenever yeah it's a
much more fun story though it is a fun
story then there's another one that
Texas is the only state that could fly
their flag the same height as as the
American flag because we used to be a
country
I was like yeah it's like partially it's
more of an idea it's like a Essence A
vibe of Texas yeah I think um
Texas is very different very has always
been always evolving Texas is always
evolving I heard a quote about Texas and
it uh I'm trying to apply it to Comedy
um the quote was uh and it wasn't so
much about text it was just talking
about living in Texas which they were
calling the frontier uh living in the
frontier you have the luxury and the
duty to change things
like just to change things what do you
mean by Frontier like you're fighting a
Mexican border well back in the day when
this was New Spain this was the end of
New Spain okay this was the edge of New
Spain and then uh the other way and then
and then when when Texas broke off from
Spain then we were the furthest from
America then it's like oh that's as far
out so we've always been on the on the
edge yeah there's a uh I don't want to
turn this into a History Podcast yeah
but it's getting to it but I I find it
uh amusing to listen to yeah to correct
me about the Spanish because you felt so
strongly so what do they do here
I just left it alone and then we'll take
it over it was actually the SP uh no
Spanish didn't rape anyone here they did
they raped a lot that's what I was
saying why did you have to correct me
then nah I really raped a lot here I
shouldn't say that they tried to come
over yes dude just
um yeah I'm trying to back what was I
trying this
well a lot of the a lot of the colleges
colleges for Missions for like Spanish
missions uh a lot of things they got
were done here so like the the missions
in San Antonio or no no no I'm [__]
it up but there was a college one of the
missions in Tech was a college for the
rest of the Spanish Empire so like this
is where we learned to convert people
this is where you learn to race so this
is like West's point of rape yeah there
we go a rape College I believe we call
that Duke Universe oh wow those are
those guys are found innocent they were
that's right
yeah I didn't think anyone's gonna get
that reference well the thing is that uh
you know
the whole thing about Texas is that
was just sort of like hey are you gonna
[__] build public transit are you
just gonna have massive sprawl
everywhere massive sprawl you should be
build like uh public transit that's okay
coming from like [__] yeah but in Norway
it's like what are you gonna do I get
around so easily if I have a car I would
go slower than I I just took the bus
well if you're in Norway I'm like you go
over there who would be like okay that's
so easy for me to go over there you
ain't driving 75 miles an hour on Norway
though no no everything's closer
together turns there's all turns like
this is just like [__] mountains and
tunnels everywhere so it's just like if
we go and air distance the same you do
here you do one hour we do eight hours
because it's just [__] turns
everywhere
because you got so many mountainous
Rocky outcrops yeah yeah you go over the
mountain now you got to get on a ferry
you gotta wait one hour same troll
Hunter yeah yeah yeah yeah you've seen
that yeah that's a good movie yeah it's
a movie about trolls that's huge so you
watch it it was it dubbed or did you
just watched it with I watched this
stuff
how are we gonna talk thank you it's
such a harmless accent it's not it is
it's not sexy eyes not it's not French
no
[Music]
no uh do you see uh
I do not care about your history I have
my own French history there's a lot of
French history in Texas too no there
isn't yeah there is there's very little
French
I'm probably gonna tell us about tell us
about it there's a lot of friendships I
don't believe you
there's German uh history too this is
like in My Big Fat Greek Wedding where
he's like every word comes from Greek
Greece kimono
have you not seen the movie no no
everything is about Texas oh you're from
Norway you know Texas had a lot of
Norwegians here yeah a lot of be a lot
of guys come up to me and I'm like I'm
from Norway oh me too man it's like
because they did this DNA test and they
found out like they have an answer now
Irish people feel and I tell them like
no no no what happened my great great
great great grandfather came over and he
[__] raped your great great
grandmother that's what happened like
you and you're nothing region yeah you
go to the race first in America oh it's
just me did you go to the rape college
and test where is this Rave College I'm
gonna go pay homage one of the missions
I I think it was now that I think back I
forget which mission was it was called
the College of queretaro yeah to go back
uh they're actually
I hate sound like this [__] intensity
but you sound more autistic than me
right now the reason why there is a
province of Texas is because of the
French and I could put that in a
nutshell and why uh the Spaniards were
chasing the Comanches up here who's that
is it the Native American tribe yeah
they were badass they were nothing until
the horses came and then they just
bonded with them and just started
[__] them and learning them very true
um so they were raiding the missions in
San Antonio
the Spanish government didn't feel like
there was any use for the for the land
here in Texas like it's just an outpost
we have nothing out there I feel the
same exactly oh then what happened was
these Spaniards got in a in a fight with
these Comanches and they chased them all
the way up to this uh to the crossing of
the Red River and then Vulcan
the street yeah yeah but this is no
actually there's the street and Austin
they named their streets for the rivers
I thought it was outside no so the Red
River would be uh bordered uh bordering
the state of Oklahoma like north of
Dallas oh yeah uh the town of now it's
called Spanish Fort ironic but um when
the Spanish got there they were
surprised that they saw 2 000 Comanches
and what surprised them the most that
there was an outpost in the middle a log
Outpost with a French flag flying on top
of it that they sent that news back to
Spain and span Spain was like okay we
have to settle something in Texas
because they didn't want the French is
this
because Napoleon started doing this
thing in the 1790s 1801 yeah this was
this was mid 1700s if not early so okay
so before Napoleon yes sir
I can't wait for that movie to come out
with Joaquin Phoenix and your Revolution
American Revolution was like 17
17. can you help us with our Revolution
we're like nah we're good yeah [__]
y'all even though they helped us
[__] yeah but you guys even
though like I'm from Norway America
that's the most funnest uh part of
History like you have America yeah
what about Napoleon Holocaust that's the
[__] German history what part of
American History uh not Texas
right now that's like for nerds that's
like the Star Wars nerds of History it's
the Northeast like when it all started
uh
Revolutionary War seems so stuffy to me
it's like I can't relate to people that
it's a low to musket like just you know
hide and shoot you can't relate I can't
relate to that my dick's not that big no
that's whack it's like I don't
understand forming lines and marching
with your buddies and getting
cannonballs through your Lines no I
can't picture that but for me like Iraq
it's like oh [__] that makes sense
because you have to go building the
building like like if I wanted to kill
[__] it makes sense I would
embody that carpet bomb yeah
but to me it just seems like this isn't
War this is like what this is like
listening to classical music of War yeah
it's like sport but I'm glad that you're
you're into it like what I'm not into it
like I don't know anything about like I
like
I've been through it but the Civil War
was dope yeah I didn't come here because
I love the history I came here because I
heard about Austin so
that's the only place I've been a daily
fan yeah comedian I should be
but I didn't even know that much
but like I always use the New York
comedy Saturday night comedy store like
um chose to come to Austin because it
seems more accessible no I just listened
to podcasts and I was like everybody was
talking about Austin is and the way they
were talking about it it made me feel
like it's like the Norway I want to see
that yeah
do you want to see us yeah I'm gonna see
how hot it is I wanna and things like
this is pretty cool for me this is like
yeah yeah
it's pretty cool for me too yeah it's
cool for all of us cool for me too dog
especially me thanks
I like that watch you got I've always
been a fan of that watch ever since you
got it that's like my God one that's my
go-to hey didn't you say you have a
Rolex is that a Rolex yeah I did say
that I have it because I do have one
Rolex yes it's a nice watch so
Submariner
oh it looks yeah it's made by the Rolex
company looks cheap
okay regular wash okay would be like
[__] big well I'm not a [__]
cheesy ass rapper it's a granny watch
okay that's cool this guy's just has
Healthcare he knows it yeah they stabbed
me now I still get operated
and I won't have to pay
let me ask be
my my friend if
he's okay with us just chilling out
do you have a blunt I gotta roll
I think I'm about to leave dude you
don't wanna smoke
I got [__] and I'm almost [__] at your
place you're gonna go all the way home
with this [__] you're just saying that
because we're recording this no I'm not
I'm I'm serious I seriously got a [__]
our bathrooms are so small
and here in our house are they real it's
not like the elongated toilet that's the
little circle yeah it's like European
touch your dick yeah walk out to the
front even me you have really big
toilets here actually yeah I have I have
I have a bidet in my toilet yeah me too
nice you need it for what you're doing
yeah and for what I'm doing I don't even
have that big of an S I just like doing
it I sometimes you just keep it in I
think the record I have is like 117
seconds for uh
consecutively getting it on yeah keeping
it on in my [__]
I just do it all the time I don't even
turn it off yeah my [__] has been after
a while I was like how long is that now
I'm gonna break your record that's easy
it's easy yeah you just have to turn the
intensity a little lower yeah can you
use your hands to push it back in
push what back in the poop oh no what
does that have to do with bidets you can
just do that anytime I feel like my
bidet works like a prep like it breaks
up the [__] in the Halls it's coming out
just breaks it up and then it's easier
so I don't really push no oh that's nice
and I like to smoke too while like [__]
so when I cough or just okay yeah one
solid motion and it matched the smell so
it's like dude I'm doing like three
things in one [__] yeah but no I may not
leave right now but maybe in a little
bit I might just lock his second dude my
leg is sure okay wow
no I'm not just saying I don't want to
be a dick but
but it's good should I do you want to
smoke the blunt that might help that
actually might help it might help him
whatever we gotta do to help you hang if
it doesn't like your [__] become
looser when you smoke weed that would be
not my [__] I don't know I don't know
what kind of weed it works for me
yeah we'll pause and go downstairs and
roll it because I gotta gut this real
off you wanna get it on the table we can
figure it out later
I'll keep it going I'm just rolling
so what is it gonna give you more Texas
history dog
where do you buy these like because
wheat is not legal here what are you
talking drugs where do you buy weed at
it's
I buy it for my friend
yeah we buy it from our friends legally
Norway it's not legal no yeah
you think it's legal here I mean why are
you so fascinated about the illegality
of weed when you live in a place where
it's illegal like because the most a lot
of states in the US has made it legal oh
you want to know what it's like to be
legal I can tell you about that yeah
please here I go with some weed history
it's going to become legally sooner or
later yeah why are you guys so slow with
that man
that's
it it's because of your movies
that you show us so people grow up and
thinking as like yeah people get [__]
up on it hopefully she'd do it right
yeah you're trying to do drugs or not
get [__] up
that's true
but I guess [__] up is very variable
in meaning
yeah
so what do you think about
the uh
the argument about public transit
because you see you have a very
right-wing haircut but you're very Pro
public transit so do you think like we
could decouple public transit from
politics and just make it about
practicality and shove it down these
Americans throats well this uh this is
not a 1am question but
um
I I kind of like it in Austin if I had a
car I would love I would appreciate like
being there and having but isn't it
ridiculous you have to have like this
high-tech piece of equipment to get
around the most simple thing that humans
do get around and you need like an
exoskeleton and Roads and like tolls and
bridges and everything just survive on
YouTube right now right uh-huh
hey Brian redband I know you're watching
you [__] creep
Ryan isn't watching
Brian is he watches everything and then
he reports the tone
well let's just say really nice things
then he won't have anything to report
yeah we like videos of her girlfriends
twerking dude yeah
well it wasn't it a joke she was just
doing it
because I love this I love Janice
we can't smoke in here though right
um not yet
you wanna
I'm ready to pick it up your ass
you wanna you wanna just go downstairs
and smoke it real quick we can put this
on P sure
Brian is streaming right now too we're
competing with Brian Brian Simpson Brian
is like a VR show doesn't he
I've done VR before yeah that should
mean Disney
okay we'll be right back thank you guys
so much for everything that you're doing
for us hello
hola buenos noches Bienvenidos welcome
in Viva podcast why is it so loud from
this mic oh yeah that does sound pretty
loud
that's one
well you're allowed too hello hello
hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello
yes sir oh wait that went down too much
hey what what do you think about the
economy uh
uh man I wish uh people would be
focusing more on making craft
methamphetamines instead of craft beer I
think the economy may be better you
think that we should do more crazy drugs
uh maybe
we were a better country when we were
crystallizing Sudafed not turning banana
breads into ipas that's my opinion
since the ipas so you wish that for the
90s to come back late 90s early 2000s
yeah man
wow that was a good time what do you
like so much about uh Aaron Carter
and you killed me with XC dust what is
that called the sugar little pack pixie
sugar pixie stick yeah man that that was
the Gateway uh to drugs for me man I
used to pretend that that was a like
Coke that I was doing then like a few
months later I was actually doing coke
oh few months so yeah like uh I think I
started uh that substance in like eighth
grade
pixie dust pick yeah pixie dust and then
Coke
eighth grade that was a crazy eighth
grade you went from zero to a hundred no
no uh not yet uh back then the coke was
a little uh was a little better than it
is now I feel like back then we had real
cocaine
now it's like just like Academy nowadays
it ain't the real ketamine dog so you
went from pixie dust to real cocaine
that's right I guess that's a lot
what happened my life has been a lot
what happened
um summer school happened I think that's
when I did it
I got kicked out of summer school for
being high on mushrooms and laughing my
ass off me and my friend Kevin there was
a song like I started before summer
school if you're doing summer school and
doing mushrooms at summer school
I never did mushrooms or summer school
yeah I was I was [__] so I did
summer school
like my people would say
I think that you should do whatever you
want to do thanks dog I feel that I
should too and I feel like you should do
the same thing too yeah
are you are you deleting that or
something yeah okay that's fine none of
this is going out as I'm gonna trip
having a private conversation yeah I
figured just kidding it's going out yo
so how do you feel about the oh then n
words no
the namibians nah
boobians Nubians nah Namibia the people
from Namibia Namibia they're namibians
right
have you ever had a nebamctomy nah do we
get all your namibians parts cut cut out
that's what they say if you're a
namibian immigrant and you're acting too
white they're like oh he had a
nibectomy get that [__] Outback to me
that's what they have in Korea it's
called a Korean ectomy
what do they call for Native Americans
they say you're not real you're probably
just Mexican
back to the reservation they say you
don't exist anymore as a people that's
right we exterminated you quite
ruthlessly
straight up it's like oh yeah they wrote
like Native Americans are scum and we
should exterminate them but it's like to
actually have your president say that as
like a whole nother level yeah it's uh
you know there's only two countries in
the history of the of the world that
have required citizens to measure their
blood Quantum and that was Nazi Germany
and second was the United States with
Native Americans
well Hitler got a lot of his ideas from
uh extermination of the Native Americans
yeah that's a fact sir and British
concentration camps they're the first to
have concentration camps of British and
Africa somewhere oh Germany was sort of
late to the imperialism game you would
guess it was like the Dutch but I think
I I think I think that because I just
think of like King Leopold and how
horrible he was but I'm sure he wasn't
the first one
I'm sure that he wasn't he was just
doing what everyone then back then was
doing
it was like Hey if I don't cut off these
people's hands somebody else will yeah
and they won't get the rubber yeah you
know who got uh most of the benefits
from that is his mistress yeah milking
him she was just [__] him and taking
all his money so all these poor [__]
Congolese were working for the queen
dog
but the thing is like back then they
didn't have good [__] they didn't have
like doordash so she was spending money
on like Silk Cuts yeah like in China and
[__] yeah silk from Turkey who needs
that like yeah like
blades from Syria
I don't think she was into that
you never know
um so how was your night comedy
comedy-wise it was uh it was all right
man uh I quit at the end so I'm not
happy about it I'm not happy about that
I went to challenge that was a good time
to quit is that the end yeah I'm glad
you didn't quit at the middle true but
every end could have been a middle if
you didn't quit it was fun though man I
wouldn't challenge Mike and then I did
uh I went over to Anderson Mill
nice yeah man back to my roots Anderson
Mill yeah you gotta go see my cool deck
every now somewhere the guy went in with
a gun and shot three bullets he missed
every single one I don't think the gun
went off I think I think it did okay
either way yes that is where the guy
went and didn't kill nobody and then
left and such beta energy no he got
tackled he got arrested yeah man I don't
know okay maybe it was a video it may be
multiple times at this place
it has that energy and it's a little Pub
yeah it's like people that's where
people are it's like a pub for people
it's in a strip mall bro there's no
public transit there you are that is
that you're not lying like that's how
yeah that's a thermometer yeah it's like
a core sample just oh look this is the
people of America's people yeah that's
that's who that they're not faking
anything they're there because that's
why I like that room that's the best
place for them to be at that point but I
couldn't stay there till one o'clock in
the morning to do
hello hello
okay there's I hope so
what do you think is the uh worst part
about
the life of a comic
well the worst part is I think I have a
like a belief like in how we should live
and what you should do and
I kind of believe like
a good life would be like you have
stability and like routines so like if
you have like a constant routine you can
put things into it
hmm but
you know things working
no like you if you if you're big and you
can have people around you and you can
just like you can set up like you hold
next year I I'm going this tour doing
this this and you have people booking it
for you
it would probably work but like if
you're in my my position I'm like I know
I understand how it works and you always
have to be like open for opportunities
like for example being here if I didn't
go to the creek after Vulcan I wouldn't
be here like you know that you have to
be around you have to try to be in the
right situation so you can get
opportunities
so you kind of
doing that but if like I would be in a
position where I you want to have like a
clock and clock out I'm here I don't
want it but I think like
if I had it I probably would be have a
better health and uh
yeah I mean so that's why you're
attracted to Comedy is because it's sort
of like that's [__] up [__] up like
you are yeah
but it's a freedom also
yeah like I'm attracted to it but like
uh I I remember like I felt like I was
not having a routine and then I started
comedy and I went all in I was like [__]
yeah this is what I'm gonna do and then
I was like
one year in my I got sick like I gonna I
don't know what you call it in English
but I've got like colitis
I think we call it colitis yeah okay you
know it's like uh yeah
so it's like after I started comedy I
took a few few weeks and I was like
[__] blood and I was like [__] up
so I was like still gonna do it but I
had a good life before before I started
comedy I had a job in Norway you know
and I had a girlfriend and I was like it
was all good
but when I started comedy I was like
[__] this is what I'm gonna do no matter
what
because it gave you a purpose it gave
you something larger yeah yeah something
that you could work towards that you
could improve at every day and there's a
forward price there's no limit so it's
pretty like so I don't know what the
English word was like it's tempting it's
like cool because it has no limits it's
attempting and cool yeah it's like
seductive and dangerous yeah yeah and I
like I have ADHD also so it's like it
works pretty up pretty fine for me it's
like attractive it's like a drug you
know yeah well I think of the future
we're all gonna have things that would
help a person with ADHD have fun because
there's no point in sitting at an office
and knowing numbers all day no so that's
can be done by a computer and then soon
the only thing that will be uh
humans would have to do with stuff that
we like to do we wouldn't have to be
forced to do anything so if you could do
anything what would you do it's like
talk to people yeah and learn because
humans are the most interesting thing to
other humans like you could have like a
supernova exploding but if you have like
just a person talking that's more
interesting to us yeah
but as like also I heard a quote
somebody said like
if if the thing you should do is the
thing that if you didn't even get money
for it if you could do whatever you want
you would still do it yeah and that's
like comedy if I don't get paid like I
paid money it's fun to do yeah I like
still do it yeah no matter what like a
rapper like I would I would be a rapper
yeah you should pick something that's
fun to do you shouldn't do something
just because you want to make money or
because you're trying to survive no it's
like we have survival figured out we
know how to survive it's not that
impressive to survive
yeah but that's all these [__] people
are trying to do is survive and they're
trying to use like comedy to survive and
it's like okay well that's not really
what it's about no you kind of have to
do comedy because you love it yeah you
don't
you shouldn't like look at it that way
you should be like
you you can tell pretty fast when you
meet people it's like are you is this a
hobby for you do you think like oh I'm
just gonna do it like a few times and
I'm gonna go yeah are you all in after a
bad set do you feel horrible and hate
yourself or after a bad Saturday like ah
well you know I tried I depends that's
fun I feel bad if like somebody like if
I did bad today and I knew that you were
watching me and uh cam Patterson was
watching me and I would do bad I would
feel bad because that would like doing
comedy where around people who knows me
and I do bad in front of the audience I
don't care
yeah I mean your sense of uh scale of
what you care about changes when you do
comedy because when you first go up
you're like oh my God these 10 people
are gonna judge me but then you can do
like 300 people and you're bother me
like well they were cold and they were
they're just uncertainly they were
certainly and just in a bad mood and
they were just so so anxious and just
since yeah they're like a shitty little
dumb but you kind of you should never
like blame the audience like exactly
you're breaking yourself yeah if you do
it then you're like oh you're doing it
because you're acknowledging the limits
of your self-worth yeah
so it's like oh you can do it but it
comes at a cost yeah because uh if you
if you don't blame the audience if you
blame the audience then you don't get
better
and yeah you'll always be about getting
better yeah it could be the audience
fall it could be like a shitty crowd and
everybody hates you because they know
you or something but still like if you
if you think that way it's not going to
help you
yeah you're not gonna get it you just
got you can't think accurately you gotta
think
illogically no in a way that will
benefit you yeah that's all your fault
you just gotta force yourself to be an
idiot so that you can get better yeah
like you know oh that was so rough but
you can get them next time you're gonna
have the right attitude yeah it's like
to be in that mind state for a long
period of time it's like
um you know it's not sustainable I don't
think at some point you just got to be
like okay whatever the audience is going
to do what they're gonna do so let me
just you know do what I'm gonna do
artistically and all the audiences like
it sexually they have a personality and
every time it's like a new person you
have to have a conversation with it's
not like 200 people it's just like
actually just one person is that because
they gain like this this is our
mentality this is what we're having fun
with and you gotta figure it out and
that's your job and if you don't do it
like it could be like the audience
didn't fit you but what you look for is
what you're gonna find so if you look
for fault anywhere else you're gonna see
it because there's a lot of fault and
things that are wrong with the things
around you but is if that's where you're
looking you won't see what you're doing
wrong yeah you're an individual you are
not a collective being no you can't care
about other people more than you care
about yourself and I think that's
something that Americans get right maybe
two right
um sometimes yeah but yeah like uh
Collective is the most uh helped by
individuals succeeding and doing well so
even if you are thinking about the
collective you have to think about
yourself yeah exactly like a football
team you know yeah and I think in like I
don't know what Norway is like but Korea
you know it's a little oppressive and
like people aren't don't feel free to be
who they are they feel like they need to
be helping Korea is that true yeah I
feel like sure South Korea was like
pretty like
like a liberal place I mean it's a
capitalist hellhole it is yeah I mean
everyone's in debt and like everyone's
working like 60 70 hours a week ah [__]
from what I see on Vice
yeah
but you've been there right I've been
yeah I don't know I didn't do a survey
or anything it's hard to figure out
what's going on in the country but yeah
they do work crazy hours and then they
get drunk as [__] every weekend yeah
somebody do it again sounds like a
sailor in Norway yeah crazy hours and
drunkenness
crazy you're a sailor yeah there's a lot
of sailors from Norway in Seattle where
I'm from it is yeah is that like a port
in Seattle yeah that's where everyone
from Alaska lives and then they every
winter they go up to Alaska to get crabs
and lobsters and [__]
but I would imagine they would go in
summer
I don't know I think that's when they're
the fattest because they got a fatten up
for the winter so yeah they pluck them
huh it's weird but yeah there's a huge
Norwegian community in Ballard I heard
like Minnesota they have like uh I think
it's Minnesota with the big lake yes
what's that called
uh Michigan would you say Illinois
Michigan yeah I like Michigan is the big
one right uh probably up north I don't
know I just stayed there uh either way
either way like did you say it was this
I think Wisconsin Wisconsin or Minnesota
or something they have more Norwegian
people than we do Norwegian have
Norwegian people in Norway
so it's kind of weird like the most of
uh they're all diluted yeah yeah you
gotta like take pure Norwegian blood
yeah but they like to say I I haven't uh
played I was supposed to I started
texting with people there and I was
gonna set up a Norwegian show there I
would have sold out because everybody
there says like oh I'm Norwegian yeah
yeah I mean it's uh diaspora it's like
you know I'm technically Korean but if I
go back to Korea they call me a coupon
yeah which is like you're not one of us
yeah you're not one of us you don't
think like us yeah you're not yeah you
want to be you look like us you're a day
Walker yeah it's like I have a friend in
Norway who has a joke about that he's
like a uh immigrant from uh Pakistan I
think and he's like yeah but he comes
here and it's like oh because he feels
Norwegian but they're like oh you're a
foreigner and he hangs out with a
foreigners they're like Oh no you're
from Bergen and then he goes back to
motherland and they're like no you're a
foreigner it's like he has nowhere to
fit it he has no home no no he needs to
be right in between Pakistan and yeah
yeah you got to be on a flight though
that's right at the airport
right at home yeah that is probably
where he's the most accepted because he
speaks both languages he looks like one
but is the other whatever yeah yeah I
mean it's sad these [__] freaks
we should stop creating them because
they're just living tortured lives we
should just put them out of their misery
yeah assisted suicide should definitely
be a thing as you're being really hot
though like half half people they like
they take the best from every Gene yeah
yeah like if you mix races that you you
get the strongest genes yeah that's the
whole Evolution cheat uh theory is based
on it that's why strength of a white and
the cunning of it yeah
the explosion of a Pakistani and the uh
mind of Asian versus uh Norway Norway
that's strength and the social cohesion
of Norwegians
so could you explain your transit system
like do you take a bike to the Subway or
do you just hop on a bus and go on a
Subway or we have a really big bus
system so like
we have some electric train like the
electrical wires above it and you used
to do that for buses uh but now we have
like um I don't know if tram is the
right word but it's a train that goes
low it's like in San Francisco you know
yeah it's a light rail Light Rail yeah
on the surface yeah and everything is
like located where we built it and also
except from that like we have the city
center and you have like this bus
station and it goes buses everywhere and
have like this perfect system so it's
like if I want to go somewhere it's just
like you can easily just get on the bus
and you'll be there as quick as the car
so is it like
um a center and then everything goes out
from there yeah and then we also have
like individual it's like perfectly
created so it's been through the years
like every other year and they will like
change it yeah so it will fit like where
people are going and what where the
businesses are so it's like bus stops
are easy to make it's not like a Subway
is a [__] sign
here's the button slowly there's a shade
and benches but nah you don't need shade
in Norway that's like if it's on the
outside a little bit yeah you just need
we have actually glass Rufus roofs on
most of the bus stops it's good so it
catches the rain we can still get the
Sun
if it is it's cold there is yeah yeah
you wouldn't want clear roofs that'd be
bad no here you would it would be like
you could do like a what's it called
Drive house a greenhouse Greenhouse
Greenhouse yeah greenhouse effect yeah
that's crazy so they have a Spoke system
a center Hub and hub and spoke system
and uh Light Rail he said there's only
one line of right right what what city
is this Bergen it's the west coast of
Norway okay we used to be the capital
and it's actually the most beautiful
city in Norway so if anybody from nor is
watching this and you don't agree
[__] suck my dick uh so you believe
this strongly so it's probably true
because it's actually true now it's
pretty confident on that one so what's
the other Norwegian City because Bergen
isn't like my go-to city yeah
I know Stockholm that's Sweden
oh very good I don't know another it's
bigger it was bigger of course yeah but
it's like yeah it's also is Sweden and
those people are not so much fun they're
not famous for comedy
what is the another what's the big
what's the capital in Norway it's Oslo
Oslo yeah it's a good city it's it's
yeah it's a lot of stand up there a lot
of stuff have you been no no but you
should come haven't even been close well
could you ever come to Norway you think
I could definitely come to Norway I
would love to ride the public transit
yeah this I'll show you drives me crazy
living here why so annoying why because
I have to have a car everywhere I have a
giant van and a moped I don't want to
get them open yeah I just said like why
don't more people here have a [__]
moped because it's [__] dangerous
yeah okay you're saying it is you're
standing in the middle of the road on
this little thing yeah and there's like
giant trucks all around you yeah I
actually almost died on my way over here
my Uber driver also he was like we just
survived together we were driving and he
was driving really fast and this car
just crossed the [__] road and was
like this uh sidewalk he jumped his car
over and he was facing us straight I saw
an Uber driver have to go into the ditch
and this guy he turns and we just
[__] barely missed him we were about
to crash while I was traveling off here
you guys are [__] crazy it's
dangerous and it's all just to go get a
you know carton of milk
it's like why do we have to get into
death machines like yeah murdered babies
and they don't even have health
insurance it's like what the [__] are
you doing you don't have health
insurance you strap yourself into a
rocket just to go yeah
yeah it's uh
it's like it's good if you have the
funds to navigate it correctly but you
need like the correct tools for the job
and not everyone can afford it
yeah
um
yeah I mean I I would love to go to
Norway just to ride it and just be like
feel what it's like to be in an
ecosystem or like a city that's just
like working you know like everything's
moving where you want it to be because
if you're like if you have if you
imagine people as like a package and
you're like how do I get this package
from here to here every day there's 700
000 packages that go from this part of
town to this part of town every day how
would you get across you want to be like
hey why don't I put them individually in
a car and just send them on a giant
traffic Convoy over there you'd be like
put them in a train or something or make
a zip line or you're gone to a lot or
drone yeah that's the Future No you fly
drones don't you I love drones yeah
that's cool yeah I got a new one I lost
mine I was flying it and then I lost
signal I don't think I put the antenna
on tight enough
uh I think it just fell off but is it
legal here can you just fly a drone
anyway yeah it's Texas it's Texas yeah
I try to do I try to embody as much of
the Texas Spirit into like being
rebellious but they don't give a [__]
about drones it's not very Texan to
being drones but I'm trying to be but
imagine like people would shoot it yeah
that's Texan yeah because technology
it's like a fancy toy I don't need it
it's like they're suspicious of
Technology because they know it's not
there to help them they know new
technology is going to be used to try to
[__] them over so they they're not they
don't love technology and no strands I
respect that it's not all good with
technology I like it I use it but
well I think there needs to be a balance
between people that are skeptical and
people that aren't I think so too so
many people that are skeptical it's cool
yeah because you need to break on this
[__]
break yeah like something to like keep
something like to speak the values of
not having it because it can't it's not
all good yeah it keeps you centered yeah
you're like oh remember how it was back
when we didn't have it we can always go
back to that so if it's worse now then
we can we should always compare yeah but
I guess it's getting better or worse but
I see like Mike I have kids they're 12
years old and like they have twins yeah
twin boys and like they they can uh
shout out to Leonardo Terror yeah
they're gonna love this uh it's my kids
all right that's their names yeah and
like they are they're doing better than
me
because when we grew up like
I'm born in 92 and like
the people who grew up before us the the
jobs that you took uh school for and the
system they grew up in was the same
system that was there when they were
like in their 20s but when we grew up it
was like okay so this is uh the scat I
don't know what you call it but those
you know the save icon like you we had
to learn how to use those hard drives
things yeah and like but then we changed
it and was like CDs we were burning CDs
and then was like USB and it's like
everything was everything was changing
but now it's like kind of stable it's
like it's iPods and yeah it's just your
phone yeah it had a disk man also we
we've been through a lot of changes and
for them they're just like it's gonna be
an iPad yeah they grow up
it was just going to be a little bit
faster like things are not like rapid
how much better can you get than an iPad
again is that the perfect invention like
people are imagining like the VR is the
next yeah you want it in your glasses
yeah it's like we don't need it we can
draw 3D on a 2d surface yeah it looks 3D
yeah
but still I'll still think I'm going to
be wanting the phone so I can put it
away you know
um yeah if you want a phone
hey okay are you telling me yeah it's
better I found yeah I do want a phone I
love a phone but I wouldn't want it like
in my glasses oh yeah you want to have
it like here but yeah yeah
yeah I mean it's annoying to hold it
maybe they could just invent like a jet
pack for an iPad and you could just have
it like hovering yeah yeah you can mind
control it so you wouldn't have to swipe
yeah it's like a drone yeah there's a
feature on the Drone where you can make
it follow you and it knows which side is
your front left and right so you can
follow my left side I can I can do that
so yeah do that with an iPad yeah
and then you don't need a whatever
because you can whatever you see is
gonna look 2D to you anyways it's just
like you know you can draw anything yeah
yeah
anyways what do you think about uh
sound overly compressed or clipping
What's um
I hate audio stuff the sound for this
podcast
um making filters
like
okay hopefully that sounds better wi-fi
and body fluids is the next big thing
Wi-Fi and body fluids is the next big
thing kept caps big caps big
but what does that mean
it means that your blood is gonna have
ability to access the internet and be
like why well somebody have to explain
that one
how I mean and what do you mean how your
blood your blood is gonna I mean it's
gonna I think what they think they're I
think I think what they think what I I
think what I think what they're saying
you think what they think what I think
what they think yeah which is I think
that they're saying
is
wife blood is going to be able to
communicate what is happening inside of
it it's not going to have sentience to
like send you an email like hey I'm
working yeah but then yeah you get spam
little bat bot on top of it to be like
hey if your blood pressure is this High
have uh say this in this in a sarcastic
tone or something yeah okay yeah so
you're just gonna be able to know what
your blood is doing and every little
part of you you're gonna be like whoa my
pancreas is having higher levels of
pancreatitis today yeah you're gonna
feel you're gonna know mathematically
everything that you're feeling and then
that's kind of like the smart watches
they have now like they're so Advanced
like with checking like the pressure and
like the
uh O2 level and the way you're moving
they can tell a lot about your health
yeah
so like if you can stick something in
and you can read the blood
you can get a lot of info that's what
we're doing now like if you want to know
how your health is you check the blood
but what if you didn't even have to
stick anything in what if like there was
a way for blood to transmit signals you
just be like hey blood put some
hemoglobins together yeah and emit a
Wi-Fi signal to me this is sci-fi
it feels like we just Wi-Fi why can't
why can't you make Wi-Fi organically
but
but this is not a question for me to
answer I'm not supposed to defend it but
like if you can't if somebody said this
is how you do it I would be like okay
show me but just thinking about it I'm
like man I don't even know how a TV
Works no yeah exactly and you're you're
trying to discuss if blood can send
Wi-Fi signals I think blood can do
anything because blood is what powers
out of us yeah you sound like a vampire
yeah whatever the blood is a new thing
like you're really into blood yeah blood
I don't think blood is that important no
you know that there in this lady try to
do a lot of stuff with blood who
thereinos it's this scammer who got a
lot of people to pay her money like
Warren Buffett invested in her and she
was like I can just pinprick your finger
and get a little drop of blood and I can
tell you when you're gonna you know die
of cancer oh it turns out it doesn't
work because you need way more blood
than a little bit
yeah she was just trying to make money
yeah of course like yeah you can't know
that
there's a lot of people who pretend to
be psychic also and people [__]
believe it so I imagine like she who
goes the extra mile and [__] gets
your blood it gets more use that's all
religion is now it's just businesses and
Angel Investors it's just answers like
people are have questions people don't
like to be in an environment where they
feel things they can't explain so when
something provides an answer like
religion you gobble it up and be like
okay just answer all my questions I can
focus on yeah trying to [__] my yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah my
victim my little Honey Boo Boo
yeah
um would you have a girlfriend right now
right yes you know the white girl
the white girl is doing great oh the
other one yeah
no yeah I only have one girl she's white
cool
the white girl you know what if you had
every race of girl in your and you
Mormon and you could have like each yeah
yeah that would be awesome is that why
you go for a race or would you go I'll
go for like type
what type body type like skater chick
and then I'd have like uh oh like every
hobby
yeah I'd like to check that's into
drones you know
would be into drones though
hopefully
I would I would do all nationalities
192 [__] yeah from every country yeah
and the Russian chick would have all the
babies
I don't know they dip them in the river
enough yeah they're tough but you know
why those are the physically the best to
incubate your baby in yeah
probably I think but I also like if I
were to like
say exactly I think like Norwegians or
Scandinavians have the best genes
because we were like the first to like
mingle with the races like traveling
abroad and bringing women back so it's
like a
all right yeah so that's why we have
like strong genes you're talking about
the Vikings yeah so what are your
thoughts on the Vikings and we liked it
we like the history guys like that
that's what puts us on yeah but like
cultural history you also have to have
like uh understanding that it's uh
yeah it's also like a cultural you have
to understand like the was it I don't
know the word for it but like the
cultural time also like how people were
thinking yeah it was like back then and
yeah you have to understand like
horrible thing to do to survive yeah and
they're not just really good at it we
would do the same like a good guy that
day is not the same as what we say oh
he's a nice guy he wasn't there someone
in the Viking tribe that's like okay
yeah you guys can do that it's kind of
not my vibe I'll just stick around and
work on the finance yeah or something
yeah
[Laughter]
but yeah I mean it's a warrior culture
which I think is cool because they you
know they are badass and they'd be like
well [__] you like they can teach us how
to say [__] you to things but then like
all the art and the math and the culture
it doesn't really slow we had runes yeah
it's like yeah I'm not saying like
before or after it was great I think
Warrior cultures are sort of like folk
like spark Sparta yeah it's like hard to
do other things I mean they have yeah
Odin and Thor and all that I don't know
when that came in there's like a lot of
great culture but I think like if you're
as a society focused on bullies and you
don't really Foster your nerds that much
yeah
which I'm sure you guys are doing a lot
of nerd fostering now now yeah it's a
it's a completely different time it's
not it's not even a foster your nerds
it's not a lot of Vikings in Norway now
we had a we did great during World War
oh really Germany was trying to go up
your little yeah the first battle they
lost was in Norway yeah was that when
they were trying to go up the little
little shoot and then they were just
like firing on them from I think so yeah
yeah it was not not a week
dog yeah but it's a guy the dog guy
a bit of a dog
um yeah would you want to call it I'm
good an hour 15. hour 15 that's awesome
man including the smoke break yeah
okay well yeah I think I should go rest
yeah me too man all right peace all
right thanks for having me you're great
for doing it yeah you're awesome man
you're awesome